what brings you here tonight well I'm
here to support the film you know it's
the Indian culture and hey it's pretty
intriguing to me so I'm here just to do
just that and enjoy the good people good
vibes a good time I'm curious do you
feel an obligation to keep up on social
media to let your fans know what you're
up to and and how do you deal with that
because I know it can be a time suck I
mean it takes a lot of time to be on
Twitter it takes a lot of time to be on
Facebook you know in today's world that
said it's definitely important to social
network I'm probably one of the worst
social networkers but that's why is that
those times there's so many tweets and
stuff that I'm like I'll try to reply to
everybody but it's impossible it's yes I
mean maybe it's not impossible but you
tweet ask somebody to retweet or tweet
at you and then you were applying them
thereby to more tests so and then you're
like trying to keep up so it's kind of
tough but you know we'll try your
hardest and just expect for the best you
know so what advice would you give
someone else that's in your shoes that
has people that are kind of curious
about what's he up to what would you
tell them because it is overwhelming and
what where's the balance well I think
the only thing you could really tell
anybody is
okay just you know everyone lives their
life just like they do nobody means to
neglect or reject anyone they can't you
know
contact your or reach out it's not
because they're ignoring you or anything
it's like they have their own life's too
you know
they're human just like you are so then
the day and I just keep living my life
and like for example as right now I have
a huge announcement coming soon it's so
so major for me and just it's a big it's
a big part of our country that we follow
together so I can't really get into
though I can't get you the hints right
because it'll be like boom that's what
it is but as that you know and then
shortly after that I mean I mean I mean
theatrical things now as well so as the
movies are coming up and made you in a
shot back in the ring concrete some more
titles so championships against are
ready and lastly what do you do when
when you just want to get away like what
do you do to recharge I'm kind of a
different breed I guess I go out and I
surf I rode bike I get away like that
mentally sometimes I'll go travel which
I'll go I go out of the country just by
myself I don't want to be with anybody
so I just grab a plane ride and next
year I'm in like London or I'm in France
I mean
you name it Caribbean Puerto Rico anyway
I just I get away by myself though so
it's kind of a grating state for me you
know I come back I'm just like kind of
soaking in the world again and then
start over so yeah that's a good escape
I'm gonna try it actually yeah thank you
right now all right thank you very much
every day